[Musique]
car
je suis ton passe à la grande affaire de
la semaine lardy view
[Musique]
et accès à tous fra bonsoir d'abord
c'est un plaisir de vous recevoir c'est
la première fois que je vous reçois dans
l'une de mes émissions c'est comme un
premier rendez vous buvez quoi là c'est
de l'eau fraîche de l'eau fraîche vous
êtes dit quoi dans le taxi merde je vais
devoir dire à quel âge je me suis fait
violer par un iman en syrie
non pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
je me suis dit que j'étais très content
de venir parce que je faisais regarder
très très souvent à la télé et c'est un
petit ça me fait un petit effet un petit
choc d'être avec vous ça fait très
plaisir c'est comme moi le jour où je
ferai de rigueur
tout le monde la vie sauve moi alors
ryad vous êtes l'auteur de nombreuses bd
à succès la vie secrète des jeunes
publié d'abord dans charlie hebdo pascal
brutal les cahiers d'esther et bien sûr
la rame du futur votre enfance en bd qui
vous a valu de nombreux prix et qui
s'est vendu pratiquement à 2 millions
d'exemplaires est également cinéaste
avec les beaux gosses et jacky au
royaume des filles bd ou signer tout
part toujours du dessin en tout cas fait
gaffe quand même parce que cinq
dessinateurs aujourd'hui c'est un métier
à risque un petit peu comme patron de
bistrot à marseille où ou crs le samedi
si dans mon com extrait bien faire des
bulles ya des bd
et des arts
ea a rejeté le 5 mai 1978 d'une mère
bretonne et d'un père syrien
c'est lui qui a gagné pour le prénom un
même temps gwenaëlle sattouf serait
était bizarre donc c'est mieux que ce
soit rien qu'en alors vous après nommé
ryad mais quand on voit cette photo vous
avez vraiment une tête de petit breton 1
quand vous étiez go soutien petit breton
d'ailleurs vos enfants sont grands oui
bah oui tout à fait comme quoi alors
cette photo a été prise en libye vous
avez habité pendant votre jeunesse votre
père abdel razaq était enseignant ici
d'une famille très pauvre il était un
brillant élève il avait obtenu une
bourse pour étudier en france il a finit
quand même par décrocher un doctorat
d'histoire à la sorbonne tout affaibli
alors resto u de la sorbonne notre père
rencontrer votre mère paiement tin oo
oui en fait mon père parlait très très
mal français c'est un énorme dragueur et
donc il officiait quand même pas mal
dans les restos u est en fait il est
quand ça va draguer la copine de ma mère
est en fait il lui a proposé un
rendez-vous il paraîtrait même où et
comment tu t'appelles et tout est dit
j'ai pas de nager pas demain c'est joli
ça comme nom et il dit à ma mère et toi
comment tu t'appelles dit comme elle
comme elle c'est joli
donc
rendez vous hillman a rendez-vous à la
copine de ma mère et ma mère lui dit ah
non mais laisse tomber parfaite il est
collé à fond a eu 10 des corps demain
19h place de l'opéra et à ce casse
toutes les deux et en fait elle pensait
le planter mais ma mère a eu pitié de
nuit et elle est allée au rendez vous et
voilà je suis là chef de cela on est
alors en 1982 alors qu'on propose à
l'autre paire d'enseigner à oxford il
choisit la libye ensuite vous poserez
vos valises en syrie près de rome et
vous dites mon père était un
nationaliste arabe il était pour sortir
le monde arabe de la servitude et
voulaient participer à l'éducation du
monde arabe en fait c'est un admirateur
de nasser il était dans le panarabisme
il était bassiste d'une certaine façon
après les islamismes au départ ils
étaient laïques bassiste comme tous ces
dictateurs du moyen orient il était
fasciné par saddam hussein oui c'était
sa grande sa grande idole en fait tu as
déjà saddam hussein étaient sunnites
comme lui il adorait aussi hafez el
assad mais c'était pas comme il était
alaouite ce n'était pas un jeu mais
saddam hussein en fait ils pensaient
avoir un destin comme comme saddam
hussein à messieurs venez d'un petit
village misérables et s'étaient enfuis
ensuite il avait il avait rejoint son
nom tu lui et qui lui avait appris à
lire et à écrire en fin d année plus
tard il avait fini par faire un coup
d'état
mon père pensait qu'il aurait un un
destin exactement semblables il rêvait
de faire des coups d'état mais quand
saddam hussein a été arrêtée et très
humilié votre père c'est vrai qu'en fait
ils et voilà il était c'était quelqu'un
d'assez brutale aussi tard comme saddam
hussein qui avait fait progresser l'irak
de manière incroyable y avait conflit
des routes il avait eu un prix de
l'unesco pour l'alphabétisation de son
pays ils exécutaient ses opposants à
tour de bras mon père est pensée comme
ça beau père était d'extrême droite on
peut le dire oui moi je pense qu'il est
bon et on peut vraiment dire qu'il est
extrêmement il admirait pas seulement
saddam hussein il adorait pinochet le
pen avel de peignes ans était le plus
grand homme politique française telle
homologue saddam hussein dans tous les
cas votre père et voulait que vous
alliez à l'école il dit et tu vas à
l'école parce que l'arabe du futur lui
va à l'école ce qu'a donnée le le titre
devrait célèbre exactement bande
dessinée alors vous étudié le coran mais
vous faites semblant de prier vous y
croyez pas du tout il voulait à la fois
que je grandisse dans les mêmes
conditions qui avaient été les siennes
c'est dans une école de village avec des
enfants très religieux etc et en même
temps ils exigeaient rain man en disant
je suis un moderne tu fais ce que tu
veux et je te force pas il y avait ces
deux ces deux choses qui se mélangent et
votre mère est blanche il vous êtes un
peu le blondinet à l'école et les mômes
se moque de vous quoi sont hyper
racistes avec vous en fait ce qui se
passait quand vous avez pu le voir sur
la photo c'est pas seulement que j'étais
blond c'est que j'étais extrêmement beau
et donc
comme on déteste les baux en général
sont non seulement j'étais beau mais en
plus j'étais extrêmement [__] lac à
l'école j'étais déjà fait des ultras
bonnes notes j'étais tout le temps avec
l'épreuve j'étais un support et malgré
les maîtresses passé mais taylor mains
dans mes cheveux blonds face était en
effet il m'aimait pas trop âge avait pas
beaucoup d'amis mais c'est vrai alors
comme je n'avais pas d'amis vous évadez
vous commencé à dessiner ce qui n'est
pas très bien vu en syrie et vous lisez
tintin que votre grand mère bretonne
vous en voisin c'est ça c'est exactement
ça c'est comme ça tout a commencé parce
qu'en fait il n'y avait pas de livres
dans le village où on habite elle pas de
livres en arabe du tout même ma mère mon
père ne lisez pas les seuls livres qui
avait s'était mêlé tintin de ma grand
mère bretonne donc j'ai appris à lire le
français en lisant tintin pas mal à à
l'âge de 11 ans vous rentrez en france
donc avec votre mère et le retour est
aussi violent que la vie en syrie parce
que ça rien à voir évidemment avec la
société que vous connaissez est-ce que
c'est plus compliqué d'être breton en
syrie ou arabe en bretagne en france en
fait j'ai jamais souffert vraiment de
racisme ou de ou de strass isation si ce
n'est le fait que mon nom était ridicule
mais n'a d'autres pans des noms débile
mais voilà c'est quand on sait qu'apple
en classe ça tout le monde soit en
guerre
c'est un mais c'est vrai c'était pas
c'était pas il y avait il y avait une
moindre considération que déjà on
faisait moins tant sur un mois alors
exemple de choc culturel vous savez pas
comment aborder une fille parce qu'en
syrie je fais un petit peu interdits et
quand une fille tombe amoureuse de vous
elle nous fait des avances vous
n'arrivez pas à l'embrasser et elle
raconte à tout le monde que vous êtes
impuissant j'étais partagé entre deux
pôles serre j'avais mon père qui
devenait de plus en plus
traditionalistes et m'arrêter pas de me
répéter que les femmes était le diable
et qu'il fallait pas leur parler et
qu'il fallait pas les regarder qu'il
fallait se marier plus tard ceux là et
mon grand père braud qui lui était ultra
obsédé sexuel est extrêmement peur que
vous soyez au mot et chaumont était très
homophobe et donc dès qu'on marchait
dans la rue une dizaine en rien celle là
tu as vu mon jeu c'est un an les
hormones avait peut-être pas commencer à
fonctionner
aucun effet si c'est ça la regarde et je
vois là alors quand on est comme ça a
coincé entre deux pôles
jeu c'était difficile de choisir ce que
si on se dit c'est un par rapport à
l'autre forcément j'avais donc faut que
ça c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai choisi
une identité
qui n'existait pas dans ma famille en
fait ni du côté syrien n'est du côté
breton c'est l'identité des gens qui
font des livres qui racontent des
histoires et j'ai choisi ce peuple là
est ce que votre grand père vous emmener
faire du naturisme
thierry vous voulez trop savoir la suite
de la
et je me sens vous êtes un extrêmement
bon lecteur pour la suite
jean-marie war bonsoir donc jean marie
voire de l'académie française aurais-je
dû dire alors que je vais rater cinq
fois votre bac avant de la voir votre
premier roman a été refusée par très
éditeurs vidéo présenté cinq fois
l'académie avant d'être élu est ce
qu'avec les femmes c'est pareil ça c'est
exactement pareil et je vais vous faire
une confidence entre loups
je pensais que chacun des miss a aidé un
peu oui à draguer oui et un soir dîner
avec une très jolie fille
j'avançais beaucoup d'arguments je le
prix renaudot j'ai eu le prix interallié
je suis d'un dernier à médard nice ont
fait tout ce qu'ils pouvaient tout ce
qui pouvait vraiment être flatteur et ça
ne marchait pas
alors à la fin
pour la décidé jeudi et puis vous savez
je suis à l'académie française tiens je
ne savais pas que vous étiez si vieux
j'ai lu que luc ferry n'a pas été élu à
l'académie
c'était bien la peine mon chèr luc de ne
pas venir dans cette émission pendant
une saison par peur de faire une
boulette qui torée coûté l'académie
vous avez été pour ou contre ferrer il
ajouté moi je suis pour tous les
candidats ah oui oui je suis pour tous
les candidats parce que je suis resté à
candidats comme je suis resté le type
qui échouer oh bah oui c'est vrai qu'ils
aient vous voyez c'est libre refusée par
les éditeurs j'ai le sentiment d'être du
côté des perdants du côté des vaincus et
toute ma vie quand je crie un nouveau
livre j'ai l'impression que c'est le
premier livre savez je trouve qu'il faut
que les candidats sage pourra leur
donner un conseil certainement beaucoup
qui nous écoutent près il faut qu'ils
sachent d'une part que c'est pas du
monde est battue battu quatre fois et
victor hugo cie et d'euros et puis
ensuite qu'il faut insister parce que
c'est comme de l'entrée dans les marines
euros mais on veut voir si les titres
tienne bioxell voilà moi j'ai tenu le
coup alors
là y'a plein de postes vacants à
l'académie alors sollers évidemment tout
le monde pense à solers me l'a dit mais
pourquoi céder à cette comédie sociale
aucun des écrivains que j'admire net à
l'académie donc sollers déjà ne veut pas
y aller à paris c'est toujours sympa oui
c'est moins sympa non non mais vous
savez il avait écrit un livre sur les
ateliers des exceptions où les gens
qu'il admirait c'était l'autre à mons et
des gens vraiment qui était mort à 25
ans il a une conception des poètes
maudits c'est sûr qu'il peut être moule
il y en a eu très peu à la can am et
casino par académie verlaine à zéro voix
et baudelaire lui a dit vaudrait mieux
vous retirer donc si on a une conception
de la littérature qui essaient de vélo
rist en fait voilà subversives c'est
vrai que la qualité parfaite pour ça
alors houellebecq français qui peut
rentrer l'académie française
écoutez je
l'écoutais qu'il aurait pu rentrer moi
je dirais je crois que l'académie c'est
quand même aussi
incarner le grand écrivain
impossible donc dans lesquels les
français se reconnaissent une certaine
idée de la france en fait c'est une
certaine idée de revanche je peux dire
que c'est la voix de la france mais
c'est quand même ça fait quand même moi
j'aime beaucoup où el bec comme écrivain
ouais mais j'aime beaucoup aussi céline
comme et j'aurais pas voter pour ses
livres elle réunit tous après la guerre
quand le figaro fait sa une sur welbeck
ça doit vous gêner quand même lot c'est
à dire que je trouve
que ça mérite un débat welbeck et voyez
la différence avec jean d'ormesson c'est
que jean d'ormesson la grand mère peut
offrir à son petit fils un livre de
d'ormesson pour un meneur communion je
vois pas la grand mère qu'elle brûle au
maire imprimer un livre de houellebecq
où on parle quand même de deux
fellations leur fils j'ai rien contre la
fellation
laso fille je m'arrête
alors est-ce que berlin allait lui a une
chance d'entrer un jour à l'académie oui
mais il faut qu'ils osent et je crains
que bien l'harmonie que j'aime beaucoup
que la très vieille amie eh bien je
crois que il n'a pas envie d'être
perdants ouais c'est sa différence avec
moi moi je suis d'aller au devant de
l'échec toute ma vie et viale mans je
trouve ça formidable d'être du côté
bernois parce qu'on en fait ce sentiment
de l'échec c'est ce qui doit guider tous
les écrivains voyez une question que je
me posais sur la cades évidence il ya
quand même cinq femmes pour 31 hommes
est-ce que ça suffit pour faire à manger
alors
alors déjà il ya eu une révolution c'est
que grâce un bon gros son il ya eu
l'élection de marguerite yourcenar c'est
vrai que et puis il ya quand même une
femme qui est secrétaire perpétuelle oui
car d'encausse saragosse et quand même
c'est elle qui dirige 12
michel serrault bonsoir bonsoir nous
seuls serres de l'académie française
aurais-je dû dire et vous en plus d'être
réellement immortel vous avez 88 ans
michel oui
vous êtes l'homme de 88 ans le plus
jeune du monde finalement
c'est ce qu'on dit mais je cache ou bien
mon jeu oui c'est à dire oui je classe
en blog est trop jeune mais mais ce
n'est pas vraiment d'accord peinture
donc je me dis à se créer c'est pas vrai
heureusement vous est immortel parce que
à l'académie on trouve personne pour
remplacer les disparus vous prendriez
kivu luc ferry par exemple il s'est
présenté il n'a pas été ému il a voté
pour ou contre
lui vaut son secret mon cher d'accord
alors sinon c'est d'isoloirs oui ciel
houellebecq par exemple penser qu'ils
méritent d'être à l'académie française
je vais voter bien qu'ils viennent louis
oui d'accord très bien emmanuel carrère
d'encausse oui non il ya déjà sa mère
qui est là et voilà ce que secrétaire
perpétuel problèmes de famille avec à
100 m an pour lui je n'entends pas me
les affaires de famille est vrai est ce
que est ce que vous savez qui est
frédéric beigbeder par exemple oui bien
sûr est ce que vous pensez qu'il
pourrait peut-être un jour entrer à
l'académie française oui tout le monde
pour entrer le quelqu'un y compris vous
mon cher bon
sinon il reste il s line renaud bon line
renaud ecalle 07 c'est pas gagné oui ou
alors en robot est ce qu'un jour vous
pensez qu'il y aura un robot avec les
micros 16 mai digest manière nous sommes
tous des robots et et vous savez donc
par exemple comment maquiller ouais on
m'a mis des choses il faut l'écouter des
grains je suis déjà un petit rôle voilà
le mois dernier vous avez fait la
couverture du magazine le point avec ce
titre la femme qui fait peur aux
islamistes et pas l inverse et pourtant
si vous n'avez pas d'armes isolé là dans
une pièce et fracassé lui le crâne avec
une pierre tranchées lui la gorge et
brûler sa maison ou encore j'ai une
folle envie de lui crever les yeux avec
un pic à glace mais je pense que je vais
les gorges et sa phrase à faire tout ça
tout ça parce que vous ne voulez pas que
vos amis de charlie hebdo soit mort pour
rien parce qu'au pays des lumières le
droit au blasphème est un bien sacré
merci de défendre le 18e tchèque
français et bien c'est triste de se dire
qu'on en est là en 2019
prendre l'héritage des lumières à
défendre les valeurs fondamentales qui
sont laden de la république française
qui sont notre devise liberté égalité
fraternité
et puis le socle laïque de l'état
français la laïcité c'est ce n'est pas
une opinion ce n'est pas un dogme c'est
tout simplement la liberté d'avoir une
opinion alors logique il faut que
l'islam se soumettent à la critique
qu'il se soumette à l'humour qu'il se
soumette aux lois de la république
qu'ils se soumettent au droit français
vous pensez que c'était un acquis mais
il se trouve que nous faisons face à des
à des discours à des revendications
militante parfois un militantisme très
agressif qui consiste à vouloir nous
faire accepter son couvert de tolérance
d'acceptation de l'autre non pas des
individus différents mais les idéologies
dont il se revendique à la république
française est une république qui
embrasse tous les individus mais pas les
idéologies forcément surtout quand elles
sont contraires à nos valeurs en fait
dire qu'on devrait pouvoir critiquer
l'islam c'est déjà le critiquer pour le
non bah oui vous avez vu ce passage
vidéo là qui m'a valu des menaces de
mort je disais simplement que l'islam
devait se soumettre à la critique je
sais que ce combat là n'est pas un
détail c'est un combat qui trace la
frontière en grand menteur entre la
civilisation et la barbarie alors oui
dit persuadé que si les médias en france
avaient tous publié les caricatures de
mahomet le grand janvier 2015 l'histoire
aurait été différente
tout à fait je pense que si tous les
journaux de france et de navarre et du
reste de monde d'ailleurs avait publié
les caricatures des là dès la première
affaire des caricatures en 2006 qu'est
ce qu'ils auraient fait l'aller les
terroristes qui aurait exterminé tous
les journalistes toutes les rédactions
du monde ce n'était pas possible une
victoire 10 maquillé en respect de la
religion tout à fait parce que beaucoup
de journaux on justifier finalement leur
peur des attentats qui est une part
légitime
avoir peur ne ne nous exonère pas d'un
certain devoir de courage surtout quand
on est journaliste
parce que quand on est journaliste nous
avons le devoir de crever les abcès de
la société nous avons le devoir de
mettre la lumière sur les sur les zones
d'ombré et les journaux qui à l'époque
avait dit à nous ne faisons pas parce
que nous respectons
l'islam ou les musulmans ou je ne sais
plus ce qu'ils avaient dit en réalité
son entendez que charlie ne respectait
pas et que donc finalement
quelque part ce cet attentat était
justifiée
[Musique]
et
alors vous résister vaillamment le
problème c'est que bientôt en france il
faudra choisir entre sa liberté
d'expression et sa liberté de vivre sans
gardes du corps après roberto saviano et
philippe val vous êtes la troisième
personne sous protection policière que
je reçois cette saison ça fait beaucoup
quand même dans un pays comme la france
vous dites quand ça allait mal ce sont
les flics qui m'ont sauvé mais oui j'ai
été mise sous protection le 8 janvier
2015 je me ramasse évidemment à la
petite cuillère j'avais des conditions
de vie qui était extrêmement difficile
et à ce moment là évidemment comme comme
beaucoup de mes collègues qui avaient
survécu nous avons atterri chez les psy
nous avons pris des anxiolytiques des
antidépresseurs ça n'allait pas et ce
sont ces la présence bienveillante
professionnels de mes officiers de
sécurité qui m'a contrainte à me
rattacher à la vie contrainte à me à
respecter des horaires parfois ils se
sont alors que ce n'est pas leur travail
parfois ils se sont fait de savoir si
j'avais mangé ou pas et donc grâce à eux
grâce à cette présence scène j'ai pu
surmonter
les premières semaines de deuil
c'est bizarre quand même d'être
accompagné par des gens qui sont là pour
vous empêcher de mourir et qui
pourraient mourir en vous protégeant
quand même une relation complexe c'est
une relation assez atypique parce que ce
sont fondamentalement des inconnus des
gens que l'on vous voit mais qui sont là
pour mourir éventuellement avec vous
donc sacrés comme ça crée un lien de
sang et les attentats de charlie m'ont
fait découvrir que les liens de sang
entre les personnes pouvaient se faire
autrement qu'en étant issus de la même
fratrie par exemple avec mes collègues
de charniers d'eau eh bien nous avons
entre nous aujourd'hui le lien de sang
de le sens des nôtres qui a coulé et qui
nous lient d'une façon indéfectible vous
êtes toujours là
[Musique]
dans la gauche a trahis depuis longtemps
le combat du progressisme et de la
laïcité
mais le 7 janvier le jour de
l'anniversaire de charlie emmanuel
macron a reçu le cfcm très maladroit
pour le moins nous avons une gauche qui
était le tenant historiques du combat du
progressisme de l'anticléricalisme
elle a complètement trahi ces valeurs là
elle a même trahi karl marx qui a
toujours dit que la religion était
l'opium du peuple aujourd'hui on observe
une gauche islamophile pour renverser le
mot islamophobie et sur le plan
électoral
là tout le monde a trahi c'est à dire
que les compromissions électoralistes
l'adage une mosquée trois mandats les
baux emphytéotiques les terrains à north
aux associations cultuelles islamistes
on construire des mosquées ça et bien la
gauche et la droite sont toutes les deux
mouiller et pourtant vite vous
l'islamisme a déjà perdu contrairement
au jeune français d'origine musulmane
les jeunes des pays musulmans dit vous
sont de plus en plus apte est donc temps
que l'obscurantisme s'empare de l'europe
l'athéisme surgi dans les pays arabes
c'est là que j'en veux aux dirigeants de
ce pays les dirigeants de ce pays n'ont
pas compris que la plus belle prise de
l'islam politique
ça sera l'europe et notamment la france
aujourd'hui les la nébuleuse islamiste
international a très bien compris que
les pays musulmans moi ça me fait ch et
puis de toute façon ce ne sont pas des
démocraties ils sont à la merci des
régimes sur place tandis qu'en europe eh
bien ils détournent les droits humains
les valeurs démocratiques et les droits
que nous avons dans ces pays là à leur
propre
service à leur propre profit et nos
dirigeants malheureusement ne s'en
rendent pas compte et laisse proliférer
un islamisme militant qui fait des
ravages qui fait des dégâts dans toute
une partie de la société qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'il ya une salle hafiz ation
des musulmans de france et bien
lorsqu'on lit les statistiques on ne
peut que s'inquiéter lorsqu'on lit par
exemple que 28 % des jeunes et ceux de
l'islam considère que la charia est
supérieure aux lois de la république on
a toutes les raisons de s'inquiéter
lorsqu'on lit les rapports des
renseignements généraux qui nous raconte
par exemple ce qui se passe dans les
classes lorsqu'on voit les les
revendications communautaristes de plus
en plus nombreuses de plus en plus
stupide aussi de plus en plus agressive
on a toutes les raisons de s'inquiéter
finalement et de se dire où est
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est finalement
la nation française c'est la communauté
nationale c'est lé droit que nous avons
en france c'est la liberté dont nous
jouissons dans ce pays et qui pour moi
est nettement plus crucial plus
importante que la liberté de certains
le choix de certains d'observer des lots
des bondieuseries auquel y croit quand
le président macron dernièrement parle
de ces cessions est ce que vous pensez
qu'il a compris enfin j'espère qu'il a
compris j'espère qu'il a compris et j'ai
bon espoir parce qu'il a par exemple
renoncer à la modification qui était
prévue de la loi de 1905 parce que je
pense qu'il a compris qu'il aurait
ouvert la une boîte de pandore dont
seraient sortis des monstres
ingérable ceci étant dit et maintenant
il reste ce chantier de restructuration
de réorganisation de ce qu'ils appellent
l'islam de france je m'insurge
d'ailleurs contre ce terme parce que
pour moi il n'ya pas d'islam de france
il y a l'islam en france pas plus qu'il
ya un christianisme 2 france - judaïsme
de france donc lorsqu'on voit ce projet
de réorganisation de l'islam en france
on voit que les propositions qui sont
faites à l'exécutif sont gangrénés de
haut en bas par la présence de l'ue aux
nefs qui s'appelle maintenant musulmans
de france donc des frères musulmans les
frères musulmans qui je le rappelle sont
interdits dans des pays comme les
émirats par exemple en france ils ont
pour interlocuteur macron castaner tout
va bien et personne ne s'en offusque
une dernière chose là j'y repense j'en
parle à ma femme un instant c'est la
question colombo
[Musique]
zineb si c'était à refaire vous lancer
dans ce combat contre les islamistes
est ce que vous le referiez
si c'était à refaire je serais même
peut-être aller plus loin
vous savez que qu'au moment où il ya eu
les attentats de charlie où on avait
pour projet pour rêve avec chars d'aller
rejoindre les femmes peshmergas kurdes
qu'il se battait contre dèche chose que
je n'ai jamais pu faire il ya eu les
attentats ensuite j'ai eu une petite
fille mais je pense que si c'était à
refaire je le ferai avec la même verve
la même véhémence et peut-être avec
beaucoup plus de 2 comment dire beaucoup
plus d'énergie
votre relation avec emmanuel macron
alors c'est un peu richman pour man
c'est à dire que vous naissez tous les
deux à amiens vous êtes scolarisés à la
providence pour en même temps
établissements catholiques jésuites
c'est là où emmanuel macron raconterai
belgique macron il avait 15 ans avait 39
alors l'un à tous l'autre à rien comment
ça va se finir ce film j'en sais rien
non mais d'abord moi je me dis que j'ai
écris pas comme ça quand même moi j'ai
j'appartiens la classe intermédiaire mes
parents m'ont donné les moyens d'avoir
une éducation je sais tout ce que je
dois à plein de gens et jamais je dirais
que je me suis fait tout seul et c'est à
linverse là pour le coup des manuels
macron acquis quand même la vie offert
plein de chance qu'ils qui a eut
bénéficié le tas de rencontrer compris
des rencontres avec des milliardaires
qui lui ont dressé des ponts d'or pour
qu'ils puissent mener campagne et ainsi
de suite et qui vient dire à la fin que
bon si j'étais chômeur je me
débrouillerai tout seul mais il est pas
chômeur il l'a pas été c'est parce que
ça veut dire et il les rencontre pas
donc je dirais que plus tôt
là on nous voit à l'image n'est pas sûr
qu'à ce moment là il ya tant de
différences y en a un qui est plutôt
replié sur lui même et l'autre qui est
applaudi en permanence tant qu' il est
comblé plein de talent et tant mieux
pour lui mais après il ya des choix je
pense que la classe intermédiaire c'est
la classe qui est un choix on lui
fournit des armes les armes qui sont de
larmes de l'éducation de la culture
maintenant c'est au service de qui on
l'aimait et moi je sais que j'ai fait le
choix de m
mon savoir méconnaissance mes lectures
ma capacité à écrire à faire des films
au service des gens et je considère
qu'ils emmanuel macron depuis vingt ans
les a mis au service de l'argent il n'a
pas jamais dragué vaccin à l'école de la
providence la madrague et ma soeur il
n'y avait jamais de rigueur
alors dans un livre publié aux arènes
qui s'appelle ce pays que tu ne connais
pas qui excellent d'ailleurs à vous
dites entendent macro quand même votre
tête ne me revient pas vos mines pour
catalogue des 3 suisses voteraient
régulier le nez droit la police la
mâchoire carrée
c'est physique c'est viscéral moi je
crois que d'abord moi j'écris un livre
ce pas comme un politique qui se demande
s'il va gagner 3 % avec ça j'écris je
fais un film comme cinéaste avec gilles
perret jeu j'écris un livre comme
écrivain et un écrivain qu'est ce qu'il
fait il propose des portraits de jeunes
ont égalé par exemple il ya le portrait
de j'oublierai ya même mon autoportrait
qui n'est guère flatteur non plus on ne
souligne pas quand on lit le bouquin
mais voilà donc je propose des portraits
évidemment avec une subjectivité qui
effaça ça ça veut dire que emmanuel
macron évidemment ils portent quelque
chose d'une classe dès que son
inconscient parlent ces gens qui ne sont
rien vous n'avez qu'à traverser la rue
dès qu'on appuie sur le bouton il ya son
inconscient qui se met à glisser et vous
savez notre physique ils portent quelque
chose de la classe à laquelle nous
appartenons la manière dont on bouge la
manière dont on se levait pas voyager
donc je en effet il ya des traits de
classe dans le portel emmanuel macron
qui incarne quelque part une espèce de
l'impression de voir débarquer le super
drh de la france alors je n'étais
extrêmement inquiet richard ferrand déjà
taxé
d'antisémitisme parce que vous parlez
toujours ma banque rothschild en parlant
de maquereaux bon moi j'ai passé un
paquet d'années sur bernard arnault qui
est un patron catholique du nord là je
consacre un livre à emmanuel macron qui
est passé par une école jésuites et qui
a choisi de se faire baptiser j'ai passé
des années à attaquer par exemple bnp
paribas parce que je considère que c'est
le ministère occulte l'économie et
notamment michel pébereau patron
catholique jeune homme dont le livre le
collège des bernardins qui offrent
arrêts o à emmanuel macron et donc qui
est catholique aussi j'ai rien contre
les catholiques c'est juste pour dire
que je fais tout ça et quand on m'a jugé
le droit aussi de dire banque rothschild
commission attali parce que ce sont des
vies dans points de passage ou aussi il
a construit du réseau quelle est ma
lecture de la société on peut la trouver
simpliste on peut la trouver sectaire on
peut la trouver manichéenne c'est une
lecture de classe j'ai une lecture de
classe et quand je dis banquiers
rothschild moi ce que je retiens surtout
ses banquiers voilà qu'est ce qui va se
passer là parce qu'apparemment il sait
pas trop quoi dire là emmanuel macron
j'en sais rien je suis pas prophète je
suis pas dans sa tête je sais pas moi je
sais ce que je ferai à sa place mais je
ne suis pas mâcon moi ce que je ferai
mais j avais pas besoin d'attendre et
d'essayer de noyer le poisson comme ça
je lis les demandes d'aidés gilet jaune
qui reviennent je vois une demande
sociale tva à zéro pour cent sur les
produits de première nécessité je vois
une demande fiscale rang l'impôt sur la
fortune d'abord je vois une demande de
démocratique le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et je vois une demande de
justice l'amnistié gilet jaune
si jamais on veut dénouer la crise si
jamais on veut continuer à vivre
ensemble que ça me fait pas plaisir moi
que tous les week-ends y ait des
français qui table sur 2 le français qu
importe qu'ils aient agi les jeunes ou
qu'ils aient un uniforme ça ne me fait
pas plaisir mais si on veut dénouer ça
il faut sur ces quatre demandes avoir
des discussions réel or la s'évacuer
liesse f pas question le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne pas question la
tva à zéro pour cent pas question et on
va avoir encore plus de quatre
comparutions immédiates pour les jeunes
c'est pas en menant cette tension qu'on
apaise le pays
il pensait que
le printemps sera chaud vous dit la mère
grèce comme outil révolutionnaire c'est
oui parce que j'ai vu une interview au
parisien des proches de macron qu'ils
aient à il est au bord du burn out donc
ça veut dire qu'on peut y arriver bon
moi je vais te proposition de loi sur le
burn out donc si ça peut lui servir il
est rincé les sort et puis disent
surtout on angoisse parce qu'avec le
retour avec les beaux jours ça va être
le retour des gis les jeunes qui vont
faire des barbecues sur les ronds-points
et donc je me suis dit voilà l'idée la
merguez révolutionnaire
l'apéro facebook
il avait une autre idée aussi cessé
d'accompagner le gilet jaune d'un petit
jaune voilà voilà
manoeuvre comment va me les gars ça va
mieux ah ouais ouais on est très rassuré
en plus la tournée n'a pas été annulée
elle a été juste reporté donc on attend
des nouvelles dates ouais il va mieux il
n'avait quoi au coeur exactement il y
avait un problème dans une valve le
coeur c'est des valves il ya quand même
à lever il y avait une qu'elle est plus
du tout quoi sa flèche s'est effondré
dans sa flèche va très bien sa flèche
est toujours en flammes
voilà je sais pas ça m'a peut-être tout
ralentir je sais pas cormick va pouvoir
rpt chanter toute la nation stone yale
et fébrile mais travaille sur un album
alors vous vous êtes vous êtes très très
fans vont porter même des chaussettes
religieux
et
d'ajouter le karl lagerfel du
rock'n'roll vous portez des lunettes de
soleil on comprend bien ce que vous
dites est et tout le monde vous adore
j'imagine qu'une fois encore est ce que
tant que john lennon sera mort
voilà je tombe aussi recueilli ces nazis
oui vous avez 64 ans ouais
[Musique]
bien qu'ils peuvent comprendre c'est une
chanson des beatles à l'époque toute
notre génération disait j'ai faite
jamais confiance à un mec à plus de 30
ans et son père mourir avant d'avoir 27
ont ainsi changé dix ans ça me paraît
fêtait
alors nous parlerons du concert repris
le phare jeune cody rhodes timide pour
qu'il me jacqueline mille le 29 juin
2019 au stade de france certes à 1000
mecs qui vont jouer au stade de france
ça va être assez extraordinaire
m
et maintenant c'est l'heure de la promo
qui s'affiche c'est shopping
[Musique]
et
oui
leur fille de manoeuvre bonsoir bonsoir
thierry alors
qu'ici ce soit pour parler de relooking
nul un concert au stade de france où
vont jouer mille musiciens amateurs l'un
après l'autre ou soit pas là d'après
l'hôtel il ya encore plein de djoko pas
compris le concept est il y à des taxis
qui me demande mais alors il y aura du
monde on peut venir oui vous pouvez
venir c'est ouvert ses publics et
effectivement je vais pas faire jouer 4
mais qu'après quatre mecs mills à ce
réseau serait encore là quelques jours
après ces mille rockeur ils vont jouer
ensemble c'est super idée et le fait que
tu es perdu le bnd tesla pas vrai que
dit comme je perds le blind test sur
whitney houston ne va pas se gêner les
rockeurs un tri tu vois la ville
musicien le plus connu c'est vous l'avez
bien sûr oui mais moi je sers à fédérer
les nations y aura du puck y aura du
grunge aura du rockabilly aura du hard
rock du métal a ouvert mais c'est arrivé
alors est-ce que vous avez arriver à
trouver de la drogue pour tout le monde
je crois que la façade du tout notre
problème alors déjà s'il ya une prise
électrique
parce que oui
ça va faire des dribbles ya eu un
casting sur internet il chaque a envoyé
une vidéo et vous avez sélectionné 350
guitariste 250 batteur 220 bassiste il
ya soixante quinze chanteurs et
chanteuses et 75 chanteuse karité voilà
et puis tout le monde est au donc on
installe les batteurs dans l'est dans
les virages pour sonoriser tout le stade
on met 150 batteur d'un côté 150 de
l'autre et après on fait les milieux
comme un millefeuille les guitaristes et
bassistes les guitaristes et bassistes
où les chanteurs devant et en chine et
ont fait le spectacle tout d'abord un
batteur quand il fait un millefeuille
bref c'est plus
jusque là et on va jouer les grands
morceaux du classique rock pendant deux
heures voilà on a regardé la bande
annonce ok
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal
en fait l'idée du viano l'informaticien
pita lien qui a lancé la faire pour
faire venir les foo fighters à cesena
mille musiciens ont joué leur souffle à
48 millions de vues sur youtube on
regarde aquaforme
[Musique]
ça c'était la première fois donc y avait
pas de public
c'était juste pour attirer l'attention
des foo fighters qui sont venus ici
d'allemands évidemment sont venus parce
que des gros l'aiment bien me faire un
peu le buzz et quand on l'appelle aussi
gentiment il a dit ok on y va on va
jouer pour vous et puis après il avait
pris le goût du truc ils ont découvert
qu'en fait avec des oreillettes on
arrive à synchroniser mille musiciens
ensemble et ça fait 1 sont fantastiques
parce qu'il ya un truc qui se dégage ont
fait une ampleur sonore qu'on veut qu'on
ne voit que la et du coup ils l'ont fait
dans le stade de florence une fois deux
fois trois fois hélas maintenant eh ben
il arrive en france et après vous le
faire en allemagne voilà c'est ça oui
c'est un truc qui va venir on inverse
que ça va devenir mondial on espère que
ça va être des rendez-vous ça peut être
vous réguliers parce qu'aujourd'hui le
rock c'est ça il ya quand même des
années qu'aucune major n'a signé un
nouveau groupe pour un nouvel artiste
rock donc maintenant c'est à nous de
créer des événements rock parce que
l'europe madame encore assez de la main
dessus
et l'ambition de roy keane mille oui ça
serait de devenir pérenne de être prouve
déjà c'est de prouver qu'on va remplir
le stade parce que les artistes qui
remplissent un stade au monde y en a 10
il n'y a pas beaucoup plus et c'est un
truc que le sale le stade de france dans
un métier pyramidale comme le comme la
musique c'est vraiment le sommet absolu
et la cedh mille amateurs vont devenir
les super stars d'un soir oui c'est vrai
bm je gagnais
[Musique]
l'accusé
c'est ça
c'est les musiques de bébés
space oddity petit bébé ouais on va
écouter un autre
on
en effet
agir est de petite blague mais l'excès
joris les noces fastueuses rockabye baby
rock my baby nos ennemis ça parce que je
vais me parler du lycée de lille i rocks
vos enfants ils vont bien ils sont
fabuleux ah ouais allez je gagne parfois
je me dis mais qu'est ce que je fais
pour que je fais tous ces trucs là quand
je les vois arriver
dix au démon franchement c'est un vrai
petit rocker ils me disent oh ils sont
adorables vous savez quand s'est marié
le même jour ah oui 21 juin 2014 avec la
même
bordel mais ce que tu ne sais pas c'est
qu'il ya pratiquement la même différence
d'âge entre candice et vous et audrey
moi oui c'est ça nous ça nous des
générations à nourrir seule une seule
mais c'est un grand bonheur d'être avec
une voilà une femme qui me soutient dans
ce projet des manques en même temps qu'à
rate pas sa scolarité à pozo simple
alors
finalement
in your life est-ce que vous avez été
plus sex drugs rock'n'roll rock'n'roll
alors je serais mort ouais non parce que
moi c'est la musique j'étais venu pour
la musique alors évidemment il ya des
gens qui en en venant pour la musique
ont découvert la drogue ou des trucs et
sont partis là dedans mais moi pas moi
j'étais là pour le rock et donc j'ai
toujours défendu sa essayé de me
bagarrer pour le rose pour aider les
musiques les musiciens déjà ses
musiciens anglo saxons et les aider nous
aider à les comprendre qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient qu est-ce qui disait que ce
qu'il raconte est et des gangs
mirifiques on était fasciné par ces bad
boy des rolling stones moi j'ai il
habille sa biais d'une certaine façon
tous les lycéens de france s'habiller
pareil on apprenait qu'il fumait de
l'herbe tout le monde voulait fumer de
l'herbe
j'étais prêt quoi avis tout le temps
comme band des beatles tout le temps
quand ils se mariaient je me mariais
quand il devançait se divorcer et quand
il se droguait je me droguais voilà
c'était nos maîtres et on a tout fait
c'est quoi exactement est aujourd'hui
sont encore là les stones et nous on est
encore là et c'est merveilleux quoi donc
voir
ce soir le rayon de soleil d après midi
de france 2 le porte bonheur de delphine
ernotte la [__] du service je pas
dit ça la nouvelle et je suis bien
lancée mais bon je continue la nouvelle
reine des témoignages de la télévision
française faustine bollaert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était bon là c'était bon ils plus
oh
selon ce soir le rayon de soleil d après
midi de france 2 le porte bonheur de
delphine ernotte
la nouvelle reine des témoignages de la
télévision française faustine bollaert
bien cool
jean luc delarue serait fier de vous ah
j'aime l'idée j'ai pas s'ils seraient
filmés en tout cas qu'ils soient
contents que l'émission de témoignages
qu'il a mis à l'antenne à l'époque soit
peu à garder le lien avec succès
chez payot surtout
ce disque
est l'ancêtre du portable ouais seront
décrites j'allais jeanine j'aurai 20
minutes de retard
il arrivait sur la fin du générique
toujours on se demandait qui l'avait
trop tard ou pas être là quand on
connaissait alors tous les cas votre
émission ça commence aujourd'hui dépasse
désormais le million de téléspectateurs
et 10 % de part de marché c'est
incroyable puisque ça commence
aujourd'hui
comment la poche et est en fait vous
devez faustine votre meilleure audience
à l' incendie de notre dame de paris au
lendemain de l' incendie tout bon à
regarder le journal de france 2 et se
joue en effet 12 6% de parts de marché
comme quoi cet incendie finalement été
un mal pour un bien alors on a fait 13
quelques jours plus tard avec toi mais
un accident de car en pologne
ceci étant il ya deux points noirs on
les voit d'ici
d'abord il ya rex non payés on l'a tué
le chien
c'est sur la haine alors ne vous
inquiétez pas on n'a pas vraiment tué le
chien chien mais il s'avère qu'en effet
pendant un certain temps le rex sur
france 3 arrive est devant nous donc on
nous disait il faut vraiment qu'on
arrive à tuer le chien mais c'était une
expression évidemment s'avère que ça
commence à les retourner la nuit c'est
comme si bête ndiaye qui dit la meuf et
dead qua non et vous avez fait comment
vous avez dit que c'est pas vrai parce
qu'en fait ces chiens rex dax on est
vraiment très bas
mais oui parce que règle c'est très
important en racks en fait c'est le
quatrième rex ah oui c'est pas le vrai j
ai grand
rex
quatrième rec donc in europe tu eu assez
assez facilement l'autre problème
faustine c'est le bouquet vous avez un
bouquet derrière vous quand même que
c'est marrant on en parle beaucoup de la
grippe se boucler
peut-être peut-être un peu trop en effet
cette occasion grèce et le même bouquet
de septembre à juin qu'est-ce qui serait
pas en plastique le bouquet je pense
comme l'animatrice
100% naturel on vérifiera faustine vous
n'avez jamais fait d'opérations si si si
si si mais je dirais voix çà n'est pas
les faits mais voici les âmes on leur
dit on a fait un petit truc tout de
suite tu regardes de st non non mais
c'est quoi c'est quoi alors messi s'est
opéré des paupières ce que j'avais à
l'époque est tombé à
l'époque c'est la vie bonjour comment ça
va et où un moment vous avez fausse il
faut quand même ok c'était la gloria
parce qu'ils sont que ce soit aux deux
shopping bien dans ça commence
aujourd'hui
du lundi au vendredi à 13 ans 55 sur
france 2 ea table manger sain dépenser
moins le mardi 14 mai en prime time sur
france 2 c'est ça alors on commence par
ça comme on sourit si on commence par ça
quand je revienne le principe de
l'émission
des gens qui ont une vie de merde qui
racontent leur vie à des gens qui
finalement se disent que leur vie en
comparaison est pas mal
sa garde un million 10% de part de
marché j'imagine faustine que par des
formations professionnelles vous voyez
les gens que vous rencontrez
à travers les thématiques de votre
émission désormais pariente lieu à mario
une thématique au collège été choisi en
dernier quand on faisait les équipes de
foot le voit plutôt dans les asexuée non
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai j'ai fait une
émission je ne baisse pas mais je n'en
éprouve pas la voix je baise pas
spéculer exact c'était ma [__] nomme ça
je ne baisse pas
capice et en créole j'ai même des
couples qui disent je n'éprouve pas
cette fois tu es célibataire
je me permets de te tutoyer mais il ya
des couples c'est qu'ils viennent en
disant nous n'avons aucune relation
sexuelle et ça ne nous manque pas et on
est très heureux très épanoui je le
recevrai bien volontiers bon j'ai des
gens pour leurs mains encore une
thématique
les intégrines aucune vidéo bonnes
adresses en france
si nous parlons football ch de jouer
alors possible toujours a dans l'idée de
voir à travers les gens vous rencontrez
des thèmes pour votre émission bernard
campan j'ai arrêté les plans à trois à
60 ans je suis est plus épanouie que
jamais sas et voilà c'est un thème qui
revient pour elle pourrait l'être c'est
vrai oui moi je suis je me sens mieux à
60 ans que car il était bien à 25,40
wave entaché que ça va durer moins
longtemps voilà maintenant ça ça va vite
passer l'invite way est question buzz
un peu en ce moment c'est un peu voilà
jamais dit lundi le sting
calme chez toi mais rassure moi tibet ce
genre d un côté
je suis pas tout seul terry wey ça c'est
bon mais c'est qu'il ya de plus en plus
de jeunes qui disent aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont nos sexes oui complètement
on n'a eu aucune difficulté à trouver
des jeunes qui le revendique il ya même
des ya beaucoup de groupes sur facebook
des groupes de gens qui veulent pas
baisser ses impôts
j'aimais under the gender c'était
globaux
les rebelles aient reçu un invité qui
m'a expliqué qu'elle allait sur facebook
pour rencontrer quelqu'un qui ne
voudrait pas de sexe commencé pour smera
ensemble on se bat pour être ensemble
pour partager d'autres choses mais je ne
veux pas des boîtes de non qu
alors moi par exemple les verts j'ai
connu l'amour à 60 ans ada complètement
le 2 mon deuxième mariage mama
troisième à pardon jab alors je me suis
je arrivé trois fois le troisième était
le bon voilà c'est le troisième comme
les évasions de françois mitterrand la
troisième était là bas elle est plus
jeune que vous tirez jamais d'accord de
trois ans eh ben on peut faire aussi ce
thème là oui voilà à mon bonheur avec
une femme beaucoup plus jeune mon beau
miroir dis moi je peux vous faire deux
arrêts
est ce que si les séries une bonne
cliente pour votre émission par exemple
je peux vous propose des thèmes êtes
vous déjà tombée amoureuse d'un membre
de votre famille et ben oui
on va dire est acquis à wayne non
par mon père
mais oui c'est ça à quelqu'un qu'on m'a
présenté sur le tas en m'expliquant que
c'était quelqu'un de ma famille sauf que
moi j'avais grandi sans le savoir et
donc du coup les amours se confondent à
ça ça a pu m'arriver mais je ne dirai
incroyable christine boutin sors de ce
corps y'a plein de gens c'est
extrêmement commun d'avoir des relations
avec battu les sages a vécu deux ans
avec ma mère
et lui et son cousin rêve absolu ma mère
m a dit si on m'avait dit qu'un jour tu
repasses frais par là
bon
alors avez vous déjà trompé votre mère
avec votre soeur
déjà faustine sur des tonnes d'émission
avez vous déjà trompé votre mari avec
son meilleur ami je n'ai pas trompé mon
mari avec son animal de compagnie comme
vous connaissez mon mari vous savez que
vous avez vraiment le gros lot oui il
est venu ici je la leur ont regardé ce
qu'il a déclaré dans cette évolution
magnéto serge on nous dit il faut être
comme ça faut être un parangon de vertu
et en réalité on fait fi de tout ce
qu'on est biologiquement animal man un
exemple par exemple c'est la vie de
couple on vous dit il faut être comme
eux c'est vrai toute sa vie il faut être
la même personne fidèle etc on est
animal n'ont pas fait pour ça donc il
faut faire un travail intellectuel pour
que ça tienne 30 40 50 ans étape amassé
que je vais pas fait un animal membres
d'un faux pas
[Applaudissements]
est ce que serait ce qu'une aux milieux
non il le dit quand j'ai pas vu ce
passage là je vais lui casser la gueule
en revenant à la maison
[Musique]
dans votre deuxième shopping c'est à
table manger sain dépenser moins pas con
en même temps le 14 mai en prime sur
france 2 en compagnie du chef yves
camdeborde
gamme de bois et une nutritionniste qui
s'appelle mathilde de tout vielles
chercheuse à l'inserm voilà exactement
donc l'idée c'est de faire une émission
à la bonne humeur sans culpabiliser les
gens parce que les décortiquer ce qu'on
a dans notre cas comme landon c'est de
voir à quel point la télévision a changé
parce qu'avoir un prime time il y avait
des girls et de l'énergie a enchaîné sa
superbe
mais c'est très con cernant et bien
qu'on est dans la vie on sent que son
voilier en leur
possible
insolent un seul conseil arrêtez le
reggae non non faustine savez à quel
point je vous aime j'ai toujours soutenu
simplement un seul conseil ne retombait
pas dans la gourmandise comme du temps
de regarder
ses vaches c'est une photo en fin de
grossesse voix j'étais vraiment vous l'a
arrêté multi de suite
m
orpheline j'imagine que vous connaissez
le jeu tu préfères on va il jouer tout
de suite hockey sur glace t on chez les
dames
alors que steam est ce que tu préfères
présenter une émission pas coiffée et
pas maquillée ou présenter une émission
avec des vêtements complètement
transparent pas coiffée maquillée away
ab je viens d'avoir 40 ans le corps
s'expose - quand même un au bon soin bas
quand même il ya des gens qui aiment le
combat est un peu dès 10h
yahyavi jour j'étais dans un restaurant
puis un moment quelqu'un me raconte sa
vie comme ça la mort de ses parents ne
sait pas quoi et la fin je dl me diras
tu as réussi à me faire parler jeu et je
déclame faut tu sais personne ne résiste
je dis ça comme ça il ya quelqu'un à la
table à côté
karim et qu'idiot je viens voir la fille
qui dit que personne ne lui résiste et
alors je lui dise non mais je disais pas
ça dans le sens résine il moyenne il
fait pas je m'attendais à une déesse
maintenant que je vous vois petit charme
sympathique oh là là on change de
restaurants violence et après il m'a dit
oh ça va te vexe pas on a le même âge et
avec l âge 48 ans et médine
depuis j'ai décidé que je ne ferais
jamais démission nu puisque donc j'ai
passé là d'accord alors est ce que tu
pourrais bien qu'on dise que tu as de
l'empathie mais que tu as un peu con con
ou que tu n'as pas d'empathie mais tu es
très intelligente à jeu je suis
peut-être un peu con qu'on en fait oh
non
j'ai bien fait est ce que tu dois faire
chaque fois ça commence aujourd'hui ou
crier ça commence aujourd'hui à chaque
fois que tu as un
orgasme sonore ah oui moi j'ai un
orgasme sonore donc la prochaine fois je
penserai à toi il se créerait sacrement
ses voisins les habitants donnent à ces
personnes on est assez dense et maxime
jouenne tu préfère avoir le quai toute
ta vie
ou à voir cyril lignac qui te parle même
stop à l'oreille pendant un an
by mangue serré il j'ai plus de
nouvelles alors du coup j'aimerais je
vois là je serai contente de l'entendre
dans mon oreille un nom c'est lourd
quand même hein c'est un accent son
accent on passe du temps avec cyril à la
fin on à son actrice et or et les arts
dr c est ce que tu préfères faire
l'amour en pensant à jean marc morandini
ou à michel drucker
michel de loin michel parce que michel
il est bien gaulée michel non mais cette
phrase
que mich et à l'époque à l'époque où on
prêt ou j'ai travaillé dans vivement
dimanche prochain c'est vrai qu'à la fin
des missions parfois on était dans sa
dans sa loge dans son bureau et y
retirer comme ça sa chemise moi j'ai une
auberge est né et je voyais qu'il avait
des lave et des carrés de chocolat quoi
j'aurai des buts tablettes
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que tu préfères que maxime
chattam n'est plus de bras et un pénis
normal ou toujours ses deux bras mais un
micro pénis
j'ai un magicien des mains donc sa prime
instinct écrivains maghrébins ici voilà
il sait écrire des histoires sur mon
chemin non plus physiquement mais est ce
que tu préfères être topless dans voici
mme et arrête avec tes questions
toujours comme ça là c'est un marqueur
parce que des questions un peu tu l'as
pas demander si préféré avoir un micro
pénis mais quand je vais dans voici je
regrette
estime je fais très attention parce que
je suis qui a mis compagnie je risque
pas d'en parler lui c'est bizarre fois
ci je reconnais pas vous dirais que
c'est la première fois qu'ils posent des
questions un peu perso c'est vrai que
c'est un peu complexe dont voici où
maxime avec une autre femme c'est tout
un tas place dans voici un exemple est
ce donc là ouais est-ce que tu préfère
avoir des doigts aussi longue tes jambes
ou des gens contre si l'homme que tu
dois les coupes et mon concept question
d'argent c'est rien qu'à voir la
prochaine
profitent de celle là tu vois ce que tu
vas l'avoir compris des doigts aussi
dois me desjardins
qu'est-ce que je répondais c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de réponse
pas avoir le doigt allons tous avoir le
doigt long ah ouais j'ai un sens et la
logique très développée non bon très
bien non
non je dis on fait pas ça si les gens se
caresse maintenant un chat alors est ce
que tu préfères ah là là c'est pas une
pièce fonctionne est ce que tu préfères
être moi vers de voir un trou de balle
au centre
deux exemples
non c'est pas ça c'est beaucoup plus
j'ai beaucoup moins dix chaînes c'est
toujours elle qui fait tout est fait
maison derrière est ce que tu préfères
devoir répondre c'est
arrivé pendant 10 minutes donc le blitz
pas si
ma naissance il est toujours là donc
c'est moi je te parler
car camille lacourt donc bon soit
réserves de brut et net il ya des
invités ils sentent le soufre et à 20
qui sent le chlore
alors je rappelle donc votre spécialité
c'était 50 m et 100 m dos alors le dos
et c'est très bizarre parce que
effectivement on regarde le plafond et
on se fracasse la tête contre le contre
le recteur la position du missionnaire
ouais pendant la position du
missionnaire les hommes sont pas sur le
dos je parlais des femmes
alors vous publiez 50 nuance de bleu
chez michel lafon dont c'est une
autobiographie on y découvre l'histoire
d'un homme qui a beaucoup souffert
beaucoup souffert d'être en bogosse
beaucoup souffert de devenir un célèbre
beaucoup souffert de se faire arracher
sa chemise par des filles beaucoup
souffert être obligés de coucher avec 13
filles en une semaine
c'est un témoignage poignant dans nous
dont nous parlerons tout à l'heure enfin
13 filles en une semaine en tous les cas
ça montre que vous n'êtes pas
superstitieux non mais c'est vrai que
j'aurais pu m'arrêter avant soit après
mais voilà c'était une seule une
parenthèse un peu un peu folle mais vous
avez parlé très bien je trouve est ce
que le record était homologué
je sais pas il faudrait que j'appelle la
fédé mais il ya des bugs qui paraissent
moi je faisais l'amour uniquement sur le
dos
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
waka l'hymne à cô
champion du monde de natation mais aussi
champion du monde de le couchage avec
les filles
bah non non voilà alors vous publiez 50
nuance de bleu chez michel lafon le
pitch c'est un peu too much too soon
sert le sport de haut-niveau l'argent la
gloire les filles la petite existence
que l'on même la grande vie comme disait
paul mans vous écrivez je n'ai jamais
parlé de cette étrange déception à
personne la mélancolie du vainqueur un
phénomène de descente de décompression
comme lorsque tu remontes très vite des
profondeurs bref vous raconter comment
vous avez touché le fond de la piscine
[Musique]
on va raconter le déclic à l'âge de 3
ans à la piscine première fois je vais
dans les bassins à 3 ans gérer les yeux
bleus vous auriez les yeux verts
j'aurais fait du foot
pro qu il voulait aller dans les bassins
verdoso
ailleurs après vous raconte évidemment
votre histoire il ya un truc qui est
très très marquant je trouve dans votre
bouquin c'est des entraînements avec
philippe lucas qui entraînait aussi
laure manaudou c'est vraiment un
bourreau 1 c'est un bourreau mais c'est
surtout un acteur je pense que voilà il
je pense que c'est lui la star quand
quand ils nous entraînent et mai mais
vraiment sans son costume nous quand
aurez les caméras on savait que ça va
être super connard quoi mais en dehors
de ça c'est un mec adorable vraiment
très alléchant chez nous les achetons
nous nasa beth des cas les caméras ont
scellé le jeu vers les îles des méchants
ils enfin moi j'adore raconter
l'anecdote où il lui firent
d'entraînement je comprends pas pourquoi
il vient me voir dans les vestiaires et
il dit j'ai pas été bon je suis un
acteur génial mais je comprends pas
pourquoi tu me dis ça parce que je
pouvais pas virer lors elle est en forme
côté un peu fatigué vas-y c'est leur
fonction interview chez un méchant mais
voilà donc c'est vraiment
tous les cas il disait déjà 100 km par
semaine c'est à dire la besogne et plus
encore sa nana djimou a pratiquement
quoi ça jamais compter vraiment maire
est donc là c'est le cercle des nageurs
de marseille et vous raconter comment
pour gagner vous devenez un autre c'est
à dire plus beau plus forts plus
intelligents est le jour dès le jour des
compétitions at oui je suis obligé de
rentrer dans une phase où je suis je
suis incapable quoi donc c'est vrai que
je le raconte comme un double un peu un
peu maléfique vous soyez tous mon
contraire c'est un peu détestable très
arrogant très sûr de lui et en fait
cette image est importante pour les
adversaires et pour moi je suis j'ai
aucune fissure dans cette carapace à ce
moment là comme un même quand il parle
il ya des longueurs
c'est pas vrai c'est pareil
et le 11 août 2010 dont vous devez les
champions d'europe rétention
[Musique]
la voïvodine star c'est la fiesta les
restos les soirées les défilés de mode
un jour il ya même karl lagerfeld en
personne qui vient vous voir comment ces
bases et j'ai été j'ai eu la chance
d'être l'égérie des montres de chanel et
donc j'avais fait un shooting avec lui
et j'avais été invité aussi lors du lors
du défilé et il m'avait serrer la main
en plein dans les filets donc c'était
vrai c'était un moment extraordinaire et
quand on fait de la piscine on s'attend
pas à ça donc c'est au cap d'agde à feu
l'est vous devenez la coqueluche des
annonceurs magnéto sur les salons balle
ovale
[Musique]
au
bristol est valable chez cambistes à
bumba
mais pas trop
quand même
j'en sois et casterman
en tête mais finma sexuels physiques et
un montant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment toutes les femmes sont folles
de vous on rend compréhensible et comme
vous êtes reçus par nicolas sarkozy à
l'elysée ça c'est la meilleure vous lui
demandez où et carla il vous dit je suis
pas fou je l'a enfermée à double tour
d'en face
on avait passé un bon moment et c'est
vrai qu'il avait répondu avec humour
alors ce qui est bizarre enfin si vous
ne vivez pas très bien vous dites je
plais je séduis jacques cidj génère des
bouffées de chaleur en quelques jours
j'ai l'impression que ma vie tourne au
film porno
je fais hop hop hop pas pour lui mais
pour nourrir parce qu'un beau mec comme
ça se ferait égaler pour tous les filles
si ce soit pour fatiguer deux mois mais
pourquoi j'ai pas les atouts pourquoi
cette période pourquoi cette place
d'addiction 5,2 et il était même pas une
période c'était une semaine mais c'était
en fait je savais que je pouvais plaire
à van avant de gagner et une fois je
suis revenu de budapest après cette
médaille
j'étais devenu du gibier donc voilà je
vais pas m'en plaindre mais c'est vrai
que c'était une période très très
étrange en fait plus dans un bar et il
ya des vies qui vous arrache vous fait
quoi et on venait de rentrer d'une
compétition et on buvait un verre
tranquillement avec les potes et il y en
a une qui arrivait que nous arracher la
chemise c'est arrivé aussi sur sur fred
bousquet pour un t-shirt 1 on était
devenus des objets en fait donc c'était
assez assez étrange et voit l'annoncé
des ventes c'est pas du foot qu'on
attention ça n'existait pas avant mais
cette génération et ça a été un vrai
choc et là vous rencontrez belle et la
bête donc là quand même il ya une femme
qui qui émerge séquelles de dire au
mieux au milieu de tout ça oui bah c'est
vrai que je la rencontre à ce moment-là
et de la vraie n'est une vraie histoire
d'amour vrai quand même différent de ce
que j'ai passé à celle du marché une
vraie histoire d'amour c'est elle qui
veut vous rencontrez donc elle organise
un dîner chez des amis vous y allez et
effectivement un moment il joue au blind
test et vous perdez et vous êtes obligé
de d'enfiler la robe de miss france 2
valérie bègue c'est ça l'art et du
défilé il y avait des amis à elle qui
était rugbyman et moi j'avais prévu de
le faire le lendemain pour être sûr de
pouvoir la revoir mais
les rugbymen ils ont pas laissé passer
la chance de mener vous avez oublié
votre montre
d'actes manqués par ça arrive souvent
dans le fier ce guide
pour donner une balle de heinola perdu
des rolex
voit donc vous oubliez vêtements pour
venir là c'est vrai c'est une vraie
histoire d'amour c'est pas comme éric
lamothe une fille mariée vous divorcez
en fait elle vous avez trompé avec un
emirati et vous l'aviez tromper aussi
ouais j'ai même permis d'entrer dans les
détails de sa mais nous oui
mais de toute façon les fins et moche
donc je préfère retenir tout ce qui a
été bon on a eu un enfant on arrive à
très bien sans voix lasse pas de fille
que vous accompagner à l'école vite
c'est mon seul luxe et bon moment c'est
d'accompagner jazz à l'école c'est un
rayon de soleil une petite fille pour
moi j'ai toujours être père donc voilà
et pour l'instant ça se passe très très
bien avec valérie et est aujourd'hui
vous êtes célibataire non aujourd'hui
j'ai retrouvé quelques uns merde
ça vous allez faire vous avez vu ces
challenges il fait plus beau comme ça
hein je suis sûr que ta discrétion te
poussera ne pas poser de questions sur
sept personnes n'ont pas d'eau non pas
du tout non non je perds je veux pas
savoir qui fait se passe bien
les trésors juste mesure même peut-être
nous on peut deviner c'est quelqu'un que
de connu en voilà
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que vous êtes
journaliste et commentateur sportif sur
la chaîne l'équipe tv et vous est
rapidement devenu c'est vrai le nouveau
chouchou des médias et des réseaux
sociaux twitter quotidien sur tm il
serre les grosses têtes sur rtl vous
allez rencontrer
j'imagine leur ma fille bientôt fort
boyard bientôt danse avec les stars j'ai
fait le casting mais maintenant
j'attends la décision tf1 sait pas
danser mais c'est pas grave je vais
rouler aujourd'hui je dirais dans danse
avec les stars il n'y a pas de style
déjà peur dans son
étude que la révision et on s'attend
même à l'ordre aux spécialités sage
reconnaître exceptionnel vous commenter
des matchs de foot sur une chaîne où il
ya aucune image en gros vous faites de
la télé qui filme un gars en train de
faire de la radio c'est ça c'est ça de
l'audiodescription pas génial on regarde
à quoi ça ressemble magnéto serge
bada
sur l'a10 est partout quoi toi qui m'as
balancé tu attends rien oublier le
fameux bayrou il ya le voir parce qu'on
ne sait pas si un goudron est en
possession d'objets ne vois pas comment
c'est
papeete
avait qualifié le show qualifié mardi
refuser c'est incroyable mais c'est fou
et là on voit tout et on voit deux
époques et idiot il a donc cherché les
déboires de nokia
non je t'en prie se demander si en fait
les gens regardent avec l'image sur une
autre chaîne et vous sur un tabouret on
a pas d'image du
sag et surtout ce qu'on voit pas les
matches et puis il a un fils dans le
cube qui reviennent sur le center
ce qui explique pascal dynamique là
plein de gens en france qui n'ont pas
les chaînes abonnement mais c'est pour
ceux en fait on est un petit peu de
service public par le signe sur ses
locaux c'est vraiment bien
finalement quand on regarde on se rend
compte que dane c'est pas bien non et
bien et deuxièmement on se rend compte
finalement que les images sont pas si
importantes surtout pour les matches de
la ligue 1 en fait
et franchement j'ai l'impression tu vois
que je vis là en tant qu'adulte mes
rêves d'enfant on a tous commenter des
matchs de foot ou sous la douche la
seule maintenant non
quand on est enfant on s'imagine tous un
jour être thierry rolland voir ralentir
le débit au montage que les gens suivent
de commenter un match et là et et c'est
magnifique d'être d'être les yeux des
téléspectateurs puisqu'ils ne voit rien
c'est exceptionnel vous mouiller votre
chemise et c'est pas le seul cas où vous
voyez votre chemise magnéto serge nous
avons sauté dans le vieux-port
évidemment pour fêter cette saison folle
alors quand j'enlève mon portable et
nous allons passer maintenant un petit
peu un petit plongeon dans le vieux port
la ceni qui fut un gain
radio c'est vous ça marche on regarde à
quoi ça ressemble magnéto serge
sans élan marcus trash ford il est mis
fin à sa pensée devant pour fadila au
delà la surface de réparation est mort à
84 ans source
[Musique]
dsta
c'est un scénario cauchemar des cellules
sont pas
500 militaires vous suivez
mais lors du match contre paris saint
germain et manchester united on a eu la
surprise incroyable ya vu 497 vie de
spectateurs dan senor 1h30 2h nous ont
suivis et c'est une fierté énorme pour
nous parce que nous on est je pense le
prime time - chars étaient ils ont
française homme de l'histoire puisque ça
ne coûte rien savoir que ces huit à la
rentrée face à jacques y aura un mec qui
regardera du sel
pas moi voilà
alors pourquoi vous commentez pas des
matchs qui n'existe pas très bon concept
c'est très politique bah oui parce que
au lieu de vous faire chier à commenter
bien sûr un moyen orient ou dijon
strasbourg vous pourriez commenter des
matchs de légende france-brésil 98 par
exemple mais l'image qu'on veut lui
apporter un
jeu les commenter ce que vous allez voir
hormis la
finale de la coupe du monde toujours 0-0
ici c'est une pression absolument
insensé ça y est c'est le corner pour
l'équipe de france c'est toujours 0 0
ici attention le boeuf qui est là
leboeuf qui en remplace laurent blanc
paix suspendues attention beaucoup le
corner qui tirait attention est saisie
d'une tumeur qui donne tu prends le
score à 0
à gérer le frisson d'émotion la france
contre le brésil pour que ce maillot
jaune contre l'éternité qu'outre les
mythes la france ouvre le score 1-0 il a
pas de cheveux comme le com comme
laurent baffie c'est incroyable cliff
vive les chaux vive les chiens vivent et
les implants 1 0 pour l'équipe de france
et celle de ses buts a alors j'ai raté
le deuxième but et ses médias tête 2 0
pour l'équipe de france incroyable
thiery j'ai raté l'incroyable la france
qui mène 2 0 en finale de coupe du monde
et c'est pas fini encore nous en
dernière minute de mesure d'être le
ballon sur le côté gauche maintenant le
ballon en profondeur pour emmanuel petit
manuel petit bac les petits je n'y crois
pas non
non c'est
simple il à la barre transversale
et rentre dans la surface de réparation
c'est quoi ces cons et la pelouse est
magnifique enfin bref c'est pas vrai
quoi on fait vraiment mais je suis pas
montré sans argent mais fais moi il est
19 heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yann riou y a pas que le foot dans la
vie en fait vous présenter tous les
lundis à 21h et
danone
vous allez faire du saint laurent au
lait de jabot
alors vous présentait donc tous les
lundis à 21h sur la chaîne l'équipe tv
avec virginie guilhaume une émission
intitulée mode des modes c'est la boue
donc le pitch et huit équipes de quatre
s'affrontent dans la boue vous arbitrez
vous êtes soi-disant l'arbitré vous
dites je n'arrive même pas un arbitre et
moi même merci je ferai des vigiles puis
je déteste donner des cartons jeuland
des sanctions nous on essaye de faire
date et les bienveillantes de bonne
humeur tomber je remercie les casteurs
de la chaîne équipe parce qu'on est
tombé sur des candidats incroyable ya
pas une seule fois je me suis dit lui me
faire de la télé lui veut percer dans la
télé et c'est vraiment de la bonne
humeur et leur même tête des bébés me
des puisqu'il ya des déçus il y avait
une super ambiance entre tous les
candidats entre des concurrents mais à
la fin il a qui voulait finir ensemble
main dans la main donc on a vraiment
passé le problème parce que j'ai compris
deux mots et c'est normal il faut que
contrairement à feu steam valve à
lincent 10 de notre dame ne vous a pas
été profitable dire que votre émission
la première a été diffusé le choix d'un
incendie alors que faustine l'arrivée
après l'incendié du châssis et oui vous
les gens préféré garder d'un standing
votre émission mais évidemment on
affrontait qu'on a vu les flammes on a
compris évidemment que c'était beaucoup
plus important de deux malheureusement
de vivre ensemble ce moment ce moment
historique ce drame mais c'est un
nouveau concept ça va marcher c'est un
nouveau concept et ça va mieux et là il
faut le laisser le produit sur scène et
qu'on aura été un incendie ça va des
gis majine johan que vous n'avez rien
donné pour la reconstruction de notre
dame
après le co qui faisont fait franchement
[Musique]
alors ya quand même un problème dont
vous êtes aux grosses têtes pour
rencontrer laurent baffie vous
rencontrez muriel robin
magnéto serge cette séquence et les
normes dans le film oui dans les
galettes de pont-aven l'extraordinaire
gardy il mate le cul dans les séquences
régions situées au pakistan depuis
longtemps figure
il faut pas vous vous dévalorisez
couleur dans votre physiquement je me
sens bien avec quelqu'un de
super à mayotte la fête les gens ne
retrouvera la maison de retraite
[Rires]
avec laurent chez laurent ruquier qui
traîne à la a compris qu entre muriel et
vous et à chaque fois il ya des trucs
air data fait trois émissaires c'est
normal mais c'est normal ça va marcher
et on a vu les mac qui prônait de l'aco
oui c'est vrai alors il me dit que la
reine hong kong grosse tête que vous
n'aimiez pas le sax et que vous
regardiez le plafond
assez hâtives alors vérité c'est très
intime quand on dit en gros c'était oui
mais on m'a posé la question oui si vous
faites l'amour oui à la vitesse avec
laquelle vous parler
de ce qui se passe sur un problème
préfère l'amitié c'était pour faire bref
on préfère l'amitié [__]
mais les terreaux mais il n'est pas
convaincu
non mais c'est bien j'ai 41 euros j'ai
le temps de découvrir j'étais tout le
temps a buzzé maija et pour que tu te
poses un jeu jean luc angers pas
besoin de traîtres
c'est ça tu vois faustine j'ai pas envie
de conflits serre ne vais pas rentrer
dans cette discussion dans la discussion
du post il confessé dans les festivals
j'ai confiance
j'ose dire que finalement c'est bizarre
quand même et la provocation je pense
marc anthéor ghellab a annoncé au louvre
il ya beaucoup puisque on la croit
qu'ils sont indifférents ils sont
inquiets
et la faute des tongiens
faire le flex ne vous intéresse pas ou
vous passer un mauvais moment babouche
panique s'en va pas quoi avons paniqué
en n'imposant pas possible si tu
trembles à la limite ça peut tenir
oh
là il faut se concentrer monsieur de la
villardière vous vous concentrez on va
faire un quiz à tout le monde joue
c'était un quiz qui s'appelle c'était
pas gagné jingle
[Musique]
vous devez reconnaître qui est sur la
photo voilà on commence laurent
verguet ch alors bravo
on dirait un réseau
d'accès laurent ruquier
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un qui a autant
changer si dans la belle et la bête à l'
attention numéro 2 bernard tétouan terry
si moi évidemment il valait 70 dinars le
bon maintenant alors quand c'est moins
facile on y va non cash money ouais oh
là là
vraiment il a vraiment évolué route
attention c'est avec les ordures
l'enjeu est la nuit
attention
et oui elle a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
compté les points en juin on rigole pas
là ses bagages attention
ma fille tom cruise beau
[Applaudissements]
c'était vraiment mission impossible
we are et johnson ont
bien eu pharma non non non je n'ai
indice est une mannequin anglaise black
est maçon
nantes était trop secrète arlette chabot
ça
va changer
khassawneh rouaix
bon attention
ah oui que la série non non non je dis
faster non tenues
qui s'est fait raser la tête là non
jeanne mas alors on a dix fermes dans
les cheveux cameron diaz ouais ouais
le
[Applaudissements]
papier est lui aussi la gamme hier
google si tu donnes à bout
ouais j'en ai
[Applaudissements]
plus tu m'aimes bien
notion même bien
oui quelques branches est non charlize
theron bois
[Applaudissements]
jennifer ouais voilà mais
attention
ah bah ça c'est ce qui s'appelle
alors doblo
sling ouais
ouais moi je suis un laborieux mois
voilà haskell pire là je dois dire c'est
la plus difficile de tous le quiz la
american je vous dois me fixe pas une
politique c'est non sanaa vingt dix
bruce willis
et demi moore hall connais toi new haven
il
a vraiment attention
bah oui la bague à la patte de procédure
vraiment
les gosses ouais ans a mis en garde
c'est le principe
je vous cache pas que 180 pas mort
c'est pas lui
qui a gagné largement elle a gagné là où
son attention sion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chan bonsoir
shy'm ça vient de shay un adjectif
anglais qui veut dire timide et j'ai
longtemps cru que vous étiez timide
puisque au jour je suis tombé sur votre
compte instagram
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu un
peu foutu de nous au niveau de la tête
c'est bien c'est pas vous là sinon c'est
dommage
non mais vous êtes un peu foutu nous
avec votre humilité non non mais
regardez mylène farmer regarder plein
d'artistes comme plein de comédiens
aussi pudique et timide dans la vie et
finalement ça ne les empêche pas de
pouvoir en montant sur scène et support
prochain non mais je vous adore gérer
ses photos on va vous voir en tenue de
soirée voilà et là c'est quand vous
regardez la télé maintenant voilà
ça mais c'est une façon effectivement
pour moi dans tous les ans ou tous ces
moments là td de d'exprimer ma féminité
et mon côté femme que je n'assume pas
forcément la vie de tous les jours mais
quand vous êtes tabbee vous êtes très
bien aussi un mail à l'armée - bien
peut-être mais voilà ça c'est le chien
de shy'm et elle s'est fait des bottes
et le chien
non c'est pas vrai vous avez charme une
garde-robe incroyable on a des photos de
votre dressing
et puis après ça c'est juste pour les
chaussures là
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est cuit
cendrillon à ce que je porte la
maintenant dans une heure s'est terminée
ça serait beau ça retourne au styliste
j'adore le prince de galles le pied de
poule tout ça franchement on n'en sait
très bien merci beaucoup
d'être ici ce soir pour votre nouvel
album le 7e intitulé agapes et qui est
donc dans les bacs depuis hier alors à
gap et c'est le mot grec pour l'amour
divin
inconditionnels
l'agapé est souvent comparé à la charité
chrétienne thieu lam au physique eros
l'amour de l'esprit ce qui entre nous
l'amour à plusieurs causes
l'allemande esprit filial et l'amour
pour l'amour à gap est d'accord mais
maintenant c'est un peu oui j'ai
réalisée au 5e pas pénétration
ces sortes de tantrisme oui oui oui
halle aux toiles de maître la ville de
paris on aurait parlé d'amour courtois
oui ça fait du bien de parler de notre
dame de paris
alors il ya la gauche la vous revenez
sur votre chute aux ragots sur la fille
je te le dis vous revenez sur votre
chute quand vous sautez dans le public à
bercy et vous réglez vos comptes avec le
rappeur dems ont fait alors en 2015 il
chantait tu es passé par tout comme la
chatte à shy'm non elle la chanteuse
shy'm les noms et à l'achat de deux et
pas lâché
guy la capsule apollo ce que ben
c'est insultant lui comme sa taille je
ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais je
l'appellerai au calme alors vous avez
répondu à la tu veux mon cul que
derrière james o voilà mais il fallait
répondre finalement solution on l'écouté
puis on n'en prend pas compte parce
qu'on a l'habitude de prendre rien
personnel parce qu on entend tellement
on en voit tellement sur les réseaux
sociaux etc simon bassine de plus et
puis au final c'est tellement gratuit
tellement violent est tellement
irrespectueux que que je me faisais mon
bas voilà le nouvel album sort j'ai
envie d'en reparler aideront de reparler
de toutes ces choses dont bercy
également qui ont marqué un peu les
dernières années de ma carrière et dames
se faisait partie ce qu'il faut dire
c'est qu'à bercy vous avez sauté dans le
public breton met par terre je suis pas
tombé par terre bon je serai je me
serais pas relevé mais j'ai atterri très
bas dans les mains des gens
effectivement il ya un point de vue de
caméra on a l'impression que je m'écrase
la tête au saut mais je vous ai pas de
la rediffusion de la séquence alors dame
soldats habillés du polymère après il ya
une chanson beaucoup plus intéressante à
mon sens et absolument donc là avec
youssoupha et cameleyre c'est dur neuf
minutes et l'a vraiment vous parler de
toula pas le même d'arthur ouais je
parle de touche parle
c'est un peu comme une confession à
l'image de l'album aussi qui est qui
sonne comme une école commune comme une
rédemption où je parle de
véritablement en fait sans langue de
bois où je parle de mes de mes démons
des choses qui vont qui sont moins donné
dans ma vie avec l'aide de youssoupha le
fait de ne pas les avoir dit moi même ça
m'a aidé à les assumer et le fait que ce
soit youssoupha qui l'écrit les quais
müller sans me connaître en plus en
connaissant que la femme qui voit à la
télé en voyant que shine j'ai été très
touchée en fait d'eux
de leur compréhension voilà j'ai pris ça
vraiment com de com de l'amour et puis à
puerto rico donc avec vg de rim et ça
c'est vraiment du haut du reggaeton pour
le coup effectivement je suis quelqu'un
d'assez solaire quand même malgré tous
ses démons qu'on a tous eu j'aime je
suis plutôt optimiste et j'aime faire la
fête j'aime m'amuser j'aime danser et
j'avais envie d'en plus emmener cet
album sur scène donc il fallait aussi
des titres qui bouge pas on regarde à
quoi ça ressemble ma milteau serre
à castres soleil n'aura que toi et moi
comptait pas pour nous fait mais je te
fais du mal mais je trouve ça tout
l'amour et sur toile à fond j'ai vu des
trucs en bateau moi c'est ça ils
montrent que cette attention
tu l'an passé quand il
veut m'emmener à voir que les temps
avaient changé
[Musique]
ça n'est pas à l'abri que ce soit un
tous deux été contraints des boîtes
série j'espère c'est penser un peu aux
vacances
c'est le but
tous les cas vous avez pris des risques
j'ai je pense que c'est un premier album
dans le sens où c'est la première fois
que je collabore avec des artistes que
vous connaissez les parties rien que je
ne connaissais jusque là bas avec votre
bande way j'étais enfermé dans le studio
en éteignant la lumière quand vous
chantiez tout ça il là d'un seul coup
cette sortie de votre zone de confort
des gens vous avez découvert pour la
fabrication de ce disque absolument et
ça m'a bouleversé au départ parce que
j'étais encore une fois cette réserve
est cette timidité malgré tout qu'ils
étaient encore très prenante il a fallu
que je casse un peu tout ça et que je me
dis que si on timidité vous avez mieux
ça va mieux bien sûr mais je crois que
je vois moi parce que je suis pas qu'on
se rencontre ça va mieux
vous avez déclaré ça une certains vont
chez le psy moi je fais de la musique
alors à faire le point sur votre état
psychique inverse une interview psy
[Musique]
je vous êtes mito
mettrait beaucoup est ce que vous êtes
mégalo non pas tellement cette parano
non c'est pas bien n'être pas nous la
boîte c'est pour moi khalis à
80 c koi no parano eux aussi ont des
gènes du jeu vous êtes schizo nom
tamara comme c'est une forme de
schizophrénie non mais je sais je suis
plusieurs femmes et effectivement j'ai
besoin d'eux j'ai eu besoin de ce
personnage de shy'm un peu poussé à
l'extrême 1 pour avoir le courage
exister de monter sur scène et d'être
exubérante et de m'éloigner de la nana
que j'étais dans la vie de tous les
jours mais après c'est pas de la
schizophrénie complète peut-être un
dédoublement de personnalité
hystéro à je peux
ouais jeune j'ai été fortement ses
compères et ouais j'avoue être abusés
comment vous pouvez vous voulez pas voir
ça elle woogie fait d'erreur on est à
non c'était c'était physique c'était
surtout dans mes relations amoureuses
non non mais quand j'étais jeune annoncé
sa probable ouais j'ai vu que je vous
parle pas du joueur de tennis merci
c'était presque bien je n'en vois pas
mais à un moment
il faut bien s'en fout
un peu comme tant
d'autres
mi mai mais klaus mann j'aime bien me
faire mal moi un masochisme qui est et
automates au centre automobile franco
deal sur les tétons rac à madrid non
j'ai vraiment c'est plus mental tant
psychologiquement que physiquement il
est homo je suis curieuse mais pas mais
j'adore les hommes donc je ne
souhaiterai les hommes à choisir sur
chauny le désert de porte avec un make
way est ce que vous êtes exhibo non on
va revoir les photos
[Rires]
je m'en plains si le double saut mais
pourtant je suis comme ça parce que je
trouve qu'il a atteint de trouble est
bon mais j'ai trouvé ça dommage qui
macule cible sur cette prochaine et le
talent fou vous êtes chamallows
de passionnés tout en inversant m avec
des maximales hausse non j'aime j'aime
bien au contraire j'ai assez j'ai
beaucoup de caractère donc en face faut
que faut qu'ils en aient aussi parce que
vous êtes gérant tôt est-ce que c'est
tous ces mots gérant tous et les filles
qui aiment les vieux comme la femme de
comme la femme de comme une poule où se
trouve le grand dit samedi prêt à tort
qu'une délicieuse femme et je
l'embrassais nous regardent jeu j'aime
bien je les aime bien tous mais ça me
dérange pas la différence d'âge moi j'ai
besoin de me sentir en sécurité j'ai
besoin de contiennent voilà vous êtes
gérant peut aussi ça que je vous aimerai
bien est à québec qu'à des réductions
par
carte et maintenant c'est l'heure des
infos 2 vise haut
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde non seulement les
vocations
[Musique]
ce que je peux venir au concert c'est ça
que j'ai un bon début
a
écrit une fois n'est pas coutume je
commence par mon pays avec cette
information qui vient de belgique voici
donc les poutres que l'entreprise belge
va vous apporter en france pour
consolider notre dame de paris et saufs
vouloir me vanter je peux vous dire que
les poutres belge c'est du solide
oui c'était le temps connaisse
était temps qu'on est chez moi
automobile quand les belges eux lutte
contre la pollution taxant les véhicules
propres mais français
fait ce qu'on veut c'est une juste
vengeance puisque vous nous avez taxer
la dernière coupe du monde de football
passe pas ça ça passe pas en grosseur
grosses sommes en revanche est une
compétition mon avis vous n'allez pas la
gagner parce qu'on organise nous la
belgique à l'initiative du premier
festival de la coupe mulet en europe lab
on a un gros favoris qui viennent chez
nous c'est évidemment jean claude van
damme était mou oui il était beau en
france vient du candidat aussi bien sûr
christophe castaner qu'on attend
vraiment à une belle place et quelques
challengers comme ce jeune apollon voilà
à ces mots sur sa coupe et
encore un outsider évidemment qu'on
attend avec impatience et lui
retirer mois prochain
[Applaudissements]
pervis dans le chapitre belgique avec
cette dernière information à bruxelles
le pipi du manneken pis ce sera enfin
recyclé manneken pis qui a ses fans
notamment en france avec le cardinal
barbarin mais prêtre aussi veulent tous
des bénitiers même modèle
façon à la france près de 700000
conducteurs roulent sans permis de
conduire et encore c'est encore plus
dangereux parce que parmi ces gens il ya
des femmes
[Applaudissements]
mais je les fais expert je suis
c'est que je vais me rattraper avec un
article voilà qui va mettre en valeur
justement les femmes et la conduite
cette année enfin un équipage 100%
féminin prendra le départ des 24 heures
du mans
24 heures/24
ce sera plus les 17h30 le temps qu'elle
se prépare qu'elle se maquille caisses
vides
et on va passer ou chiraco chirac à sa
soeur paule infos de la semaine elle a
parlé claude chirac la fille et elle dit
en fait elle se tapait le travail et ils
en récolter les fruits alors aujourd'hui
ça a bien changé autant c'était jacques
qui récoltaient des fruits autant
maintenant c'est bernadette qui a
récolté le légume
ah ouais ouais c'est là je suis belge
mais je ne rends pas compte politique
internationale aux rebelles en légumes à
notre algérie bouteflika
démissionne voilà pour la première fois
en 20 ans l'algérie s'est réveillée sans
doute et flic à sa tête et comme tous
les jours depuis 20 ans bouteflika ne
s'est pas réveillé
face aux etats unis elle est noire
homosexuels mère de famille laurine
lightfoot est la nouvelle maire de
chicago et bien je peux clairement vous
l'annoncer il n'y aura pas de jumelage
entre chicago et béziers cette amère
pologne un des prêtres brûlent des
livres des sagas harry potter et
twilight je comprends pas cette haine
contre harry potter un jeune qui joue
avec sa baguette magique ça devrait
plaire à auprès
allégé petites pages médecine pour objet
on commence voit la contraception une
pilule masculine donne des premiers
résultats encourageants et c'est vrai ça
a l'air plutôt efficace depuis longtemps
la pilule aucun homme n'est tombée
enceinte
[Applaudissements]
autant expériences de ma appris
l'existence cette semaine la nasa
recherche des volontaires pour seize
mille cinq cents euros
resté allongé deux mois réactions sur
twitter et d'amandes michael schumacher
est pas renié voulait 16500 bas si vous
voulez je fais ça depuis des années
qu'un
autre
faux une femme accuse son dentiste
d'avoir introduit son sexe dans sa
bouche pendant une conversation
heureusement qu'elle est au rendez vous
chez le proctologue
je les fais rapidement parce que je
sentais qu'elle pouvait venir de là ces
gens ramènent plein complet voilà sans
transition justement les sondages inhalé
rectal seront désormais désinfecter
après chaque utilisation si c'est vrai
toutes mes pensées vont aux gens qui ont
dû passer un examen vaginale loretta
avant cette décision et on termine 7e
partira filets par une décision de
justice australienne apparemment péter
sur ses collègues n'est pas du
harcèlement oui pardon c'est une
décision du juge de paix évidemment et
oui bah oui
et là les vrais allait bien aller bien
oui enfin je dis toujours pas retenu
furoncle eau qu
on va faire un truc ensemble
conso auchan reconnaît avoir vendu des
sacs banham avec une croix gammée en
pologne c'est terrible c'est choquant
enfin j'avais quand 2019 on vend encore
des sacs banham
people
divorce au bout de quatre jours nicolas
qu'es tu s'est marié sur un coup de tête
car il était trop saoul faudra quand
même pensé à vérifier que christophe
castaner n'a pas passé la bague au doigt
de clara l'autre soir et après une école
sketches en fait j'ai l'impression que
certes il s'est marié parce qu'il était
ivre mais je pense que son styliste a
également profité de son état pour se
[__] de sa gueule à quelques occasions
mode justement emma coronel la femme
belle chapeau créer une ligne de
vêtements ça de lui faire tout bizarre
de créer une ligne combat pacini fait
mais je pense que ça va tu souhaites il
y aura de tout d'elle chapeau melon des
chapeaux hauts-de-forme des chiffres
connus
les enfants
et les vrais vannes elle devait
s'occuper d'un cochon sauvé par une
association elle en fait du pakistan
pourvu qu'ils deviennent jamais famille
d'accueil
au nord-mali surpris en train d'abuser
d'un mouton il est condamné à 300 euros
à quelqu'un qui avait pas compris le
principe du jeu saute mouton accepté de
sauter au dessus de 2 dans
un malentendu sur une histoire de petit
beat fini en bagarre générale en france
et qui est une faute d'orthographe et
bien non
évidemment ça vous arriverez pas mais en
fait c'est vraiment arrivé c'est une
voiture qui arrivait pas à sortir la
place de parking et les gens ont voulu
l'aider et le gars a dit laisser à cause
de la petite [__] donc ils l'ont pris
pour eux à cause de l'alcool et péter la
gueule véridique
riddick véridique hiver et d'ixelles a
valu un tweet de christian quesada qui
nous dit moi aussi tout le monde ment
merde pour une histoire de petit but
aller l'artiste la semaine à chaque
semaine je propose une visite et eybens
comme lara et là je me remette à
bruxelles je la région mène à bruxelles
un artiste belge choisir une co 17
pascal bernier il est né en 1960 et son
oeuvre relève à la fois de la nature
morte de l'art mortuaire et de la
taxidermie alors évidemment fait bien la
différence entre un taxidermiste et un
zoophiles taxidermiste il pour un animal
et le bourg de paille zoophiles voilà
les deux bouts voilà voilà
voilà et il a fait plein d'animaux c'est
assez marrant voilà ici on a un groupe
d'animaux qui revient sans doute d'une
manif gilet jaune et quelques autres
exemples c'est assez mignon voilà tout
le monde se rappelle de bibi phoque et
ses bobos fox celui ci oui des enfants
qui regardent faisant une petite blague
autre animal voilà ben m'hidi c'est un
mélange entre un gambit et lady di
très très bien le côté panpan cas c'est
amusant à ses lapins 4 bien coup le
fameux coup du lapin oh que oui et plein
de bugs pour les enfants retraduire le
poussin le poussèrent là qu'ils se
débrouillent leur il peut depuis qu'on a
annulé la vente de hidjab chez décathlon
est ici de l'artiste avec une de ses
créations apparemment il a pris
l'expression balances ton port au pied
de la lettre
et aussi peut-être le plus mignon c'est
petit écureuil qui a découvert à son
insu bac une noisette c'est beaucoup
plus facile a réceptionné au pied d'un
arbre qu'une noix de coco
et plus surprenant une oeuvre qui
pourrait s'intituler accident de travail
pour rocco siffredi
ces cadeaux c'est pourquoi crack ou
l'amener oui
y'a pas que des animaux classés
ya pas que les animaux plâtre et
évidemment il ya encore
l'artiste lui-même pascal bernier l'a
baptisé perversion bipolaire ou le
cauchemar de marine le pen un brin qu'en
q1 blanc
alors y'a pas que des animaux dans
l'oeuvre de vernier mais une passion
pour la mort qui suit toute son oeuvre
prenez ça voila voila c'est il a la
pêche pour 93 ans valérie giscard des
braises intéressante aussi cette offre
parce qu'on découvre enfin ce qui se
cache dans le cerveau du créateur de
desigual
s'est lassé par jean paul franc je
reçois le fait leur
temps ici enfin on a retrouvé des deux
premiers candidats de fort boyard était
coincé dans l'épreuve pas évidente à
l'époque encore je vous dis qu'il est
angoissé par la mort il ya
d'installation sympa qui s'appelle
funeral tech dans chacune des petites
sépulture reposer un appareil mobile aux
smartphones si on est plus près en
regardant la dernière merveille d'apple
là il tombe je suis perdue connecter
sans doute qui calcule le nombre
d'asticots les cercueils voisins il n'y
a pas que la technologie regardez ici
comme des mignonnes la future tombe de
patrick sébastien parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on est serré au fond de cette boîte
bravo terminons par un dessin de pascal
dernier qui compte que c'est un vrai
artiste contemporain puisqu'il n'est pas
contre l'idée d' [__] des mouches
allez donc le voir à l'atelier 30
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu